my childhood was not great it was
you know dad passed early
uh you know single mom
like
new sister just like did not handle it
great and you know it was you go new
sister you're saying your mom had she
had my sister was like two three years
old okay so like it was just like a
[ __ ] nightmare um so like my family
was just great the whole time they they
were really and they were super
supportive of me trying stand up uh
because they were like whatev whatever
makes you happy so
uh definitely a family guy my favorite
thing ever which i've yet to achieve is
i want to have a kid
uh wow that's like my dream wow yeah and
so it's like super corny but like i just
like i don't talk about super coins the
best goddamn thing you could do just
like it's it's it would be so fun to
dress up a little dude like or you know
like you saw it's just like i'm so
excited for like that chapter so like
that's kind of what i'm just preparing
for now is trying to be like as good as
a dude and develop and get better so
when that happens it's just easier you
know what's crazy i think about this all
the time you know i've heard you
talk about your father you know we i
know how your dad passed away at 9 11.
um you know you've always had a dark
side of humor towards it um which is a
mechanism for dealing with it you know i
was the same way with my dad
and
drug addiction how i dealt with it how i
talked about it my approach to making
other people laugh at it almost acted as
a as a calm for me right that acted as
my therapy but also you know it helped
me his his ups and downs kind of showed
me the road not to go down especially
when you're talking about being a parent
yeah i'm still going bumping my head i'm
still going back if everything was all
peachy at home kevin you wouldn't be
here no not at all i tell my friends
that all the time i'm like if i if
everything was my childhood was fine i'd
probably be a construction worker and
stand out and be the happiest guy ever
but like that weird [ __ ] that it does to
you
and
made me
love comedy
[Music]
you